one of the victims in Santa Fe is
17-year old Christopher stone he was
shot and killed in his first period art
class he was a football player described
his adventurous and funny
Mireya Villarreal spoke to his older
sisters about Chris's final moments have
you been told about what's happened we
were told by a student that was with him
that Chris was trying to escape the room
didn't succeed but he did go into a
closet with other kids and he was the
one to help hold the door closed and he
did shoot through the door and they
hit my brother good boy that was Thomas
he stayed and he prayed with my brother
wasn't a little you know always be
grateful for that and um
many kids are saying I have a word for
Chris the other kids in the room
probably would have been down as well
our brother was selfless he was
he was our baby brother but he was our
big brother in so many ways he was so
gentle anyone that knew him were touched
by him and I just don't think he
deserved anything that happened to him
but we know he's still with us
and he'll always be in our hearts the
sisters want their brother to be
remembered rather for how he lived and
not how he died they also say they do
not plan to forgive the shooter